hi my name is markiplier and I'm here
with my mom
also known as mom applier hi everybody
yeah and it's bail guys bail today we're
going to be doing the how well do you
know your child game something like that
it's an official name for it is
something like a parent tag I don't know
what this is years old at this point but
I figured it was a good time for the
audience to know if you know me very
well
I'll ask I guess I'll do all the work
okay who are my enemies give you do over
say it again what's going on you are my
enemy
[Music]
jacksepticeye because you guys can't
neck-in-neck
I don't know what kind of ruthless world
do you think YouTube is he's just
competition to each other oh they trying
to step each other's back
well oh I'll tell I'll tell Jack that
when I see him later today my answer was
the haters what is my favorite music now
think about it
what did you make the album what's the
title of this song wasn't I made it help
yeah you go
something you sing with a guitar what is
the name of this oh I did a cover cover
what was the title I did it was all
that's coming to mind is oh say can you
see but that's not it no that was come
on what was it I'm trying to remember oh
wait okay it's it's Ed Sheeran's that
epic ballad oh say can you see that was
it that's it yeah it's Ross my favorite
band is here come the mummies is awesome
awesome
okay now we're getting into the serious
questions what is my biggest complaint
about this family this family which
family our family complete yeah what's
my biggest complaint oh wait I know well
I haven't written the answer yet I know
what don't even written is she hang on
okay what is it I think I know what just
talking about as your agent pills you
know what we like to do force-feeding
children first thing I ask is are you
hungry
wait a minute I cook for you that's not
a complaint no my complaint was I don't
get to see you all but I love the clip
of
but my last answer was lovely if I could
buy you and this is a little reverse if
I could buy you anything in the here
actually I'll just give you this here
write down write down your answer
I'll take bubble or Bell that's Bell yes
a bell I'll think about rule now you
write down your answer to this question
okay
don't show me if I could buy you
anything in the world what would it be I
know right
don't let me see it but now I'm gonna
answer anything if I could buy you
anything in the world for shopping
your brother is pretty sure writing a
wad any one thing
Oh any one thing have to be anyone how
am I gonna get supergiant things
don't disappoint itself this isn't
reality I'm not actually gonna buy you
these things this is what I want
don't show me I have an answer yes okay
I got a guess it alright
is it okay you broke down multiple
things a new car a new house an island
in the Bahamas pay vacation a a fleet of
servants to clean and cook for you did I
get it wrong
I personally you don't know me
apparently I don't
it was this seal saving bill we said
look like looks like Bell is a mermaid
yeah bill weir did yeah another belt boy
Bell
you I want me I want them to have a nice
puppet
there's too many dogs in the world you
don't need to breed them they don't make
it there many puppies if they're lucky
if I'm lucky they might have one alright
well you got me good on that one okay so
that's a point - for me perfect rate an
extra man by the way nice try
I've been practicing all right what is
my favorite TV show
well dr. house don't know either one
what's the line
what's the line yeah who's the man who's
the line is it anyway yeah yeah yeah I
don't know what doctor or no house came
into that well yeah yeah good thing you
settled on whose line is it anyway cuz
that's my favorite show you watch
everything okay this one will probably
be an easy one what accomplishment am I
most proud of raising money for charity
am I too fast no yeah
which allowed me to raise money yes our
YouTube channel
yeah donate $1 for you if you didn't
have a good channel yeah right we'll
count that as point yeah that point hmm
okay I got an answer this might be tough
for you um what was my biggest
disappointment of this past year there's
so many disappointments just this year
just as past year oh I guess that would
have been a disappointment yeah but
let's focus on like disappointments that
were my fault
cuz getting sick wasn't my fault let's
say that I did something and I I
disappointed yeah something about the
beginning this video might disagree with
that but I just put like my bad habits
well it's so hard like this is like this
basically it's I I'm so ingrained at
this point into like a certain habit of
like making things and like living my
life that it's it's it's just like super
hard to get into good habits when I've
got so many bad habits that are in the
way so like getting up to exercise in
the morning me and consistent about
Korean lessons like exiled yourself this
is a funny question do you think do you
think I feel too big or too small for my
age to be am I too big to talk you small
for my age you're not quite six-foot you
understood he just went off on a tangent
am I too big or too small for my age
what do you think I think
I cannot say that I'm too big to be too
big I guess a fat guess I could use it
lose a few pounds oh my egos too huge to
schools
no no I'm hurtin let's do that again
okay answer your answer again whoa am I
too big or too small it's a small okay
what chore do or did I hate the most
[Laughter]
I guess what gift from you have I
cherished the most your mom and there is
just normal every stream yes and I
produce this product I think this in
some way is a correct answer because I
put unconditional support you know I can
support all day long but if you look
like if I'm a girl I feel ugly I don't
think you can have unconditional support
harsh realities from mom apply you
I've got support from me from blessing
of sanity mutation of freak is what
you're saying I was saying like you know
not at first when I first told you I was
dropping out of college things got a
little dicey but after after I started
once you realized I started I could make
money from this like your number one
family the whole way through so that's
always good it's always it's always nice
to be able to come home and have like
food cook hey let me tell you as your
mother
have I ever say no to whatever you are
doing oh you were a little upset when
you realized I was skipping classes to
do YouTube so that things turned out for
the best
mm-hmm before I get really didn't have a
time for me to get upset make sense to
me okay I think that's good enough for
there so thank you everybody so much for
watching this has been my mom she has no
social media account so I can't plug her
in anyway
but you know thanks mom for being there
for me and even though you only got like
three questions right
I think I'll still give you a passing
grade I think I'll look up some
questions for how well I know you and
then we can do a video like that thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more stuff like this let
me know down in the comments below and
also I'm gonna be going on tour in
Australia and we'll come to back to
Amsterdam in July Australia's in
November Amsterdam in July check out for
tickets and to Del Mar flyer calm or on
the link in the description below thanks
everybody for watching and as always see
you
[Music]